jean françois copé a failli à accepter
démissionner c'était ce qu'il fallait
faire le parti est en crise la sphère
bygmalion est révélée au grand public
on se rend compte qu'il ya des vraies
questions qui se posent sur le
financement interne de l'ump et que les
équipes copé sont accusés d'avoir
organisé tout ça j'ai envie dire le
règlement de comptes autour de jean
françois copé qui est extrêmement
violent c'est à dire que les élus se
réunissent en lui disant tu dois partir
maintenant ça suffit il faut que tu t'en
ailles donc il ya cet épisode aussi qui
rajoute une couche supplémentaire aux
guerres et aux divisions notamment
nathalie kosciusko morizet a été très
offensive donc ça aussi ça laisse des
traces
[Musique]
le 15 juin 2014 jean françois copé
embourbé dans la sphère bygmalion
démissionne de la présidence de l'ump
et c'est un visage bien connu des
militants qui va faire son retour sur le
devant de la scène
[Musique]
le retour de sarkozy il est inscrit
j'allais lire d'abord dans son adn parce
que comme le dit patrick buisson on n'a
jamais vu un tigre devenir végétarien
donc on n'a jamais vu un homme politique
du niveau d'un ancien président de la
république renoncé à revenir en
politique il a jamais vraiment accepté
sa défaite de 2012 parce que l été une
défaite de pas beaucoup et qui
considérait que s'il avait eu plus de
temps pour faire campagne si certaines
conditions avaient été mieux réunis ils
auraient pu gagner cette élection de
vidéos donc il veut il veut sa revanche
ils étaient très motivés pour ça et donc
c'est ce qui explique son retour et
surtout ils voient que après lui va au
fond d'eux les gens se déchire ce qu'il
a créées est en train de partir en
lambeaux
les militants de l'ump ce sont des
militants pour la plupart qui est sont
venus pour lui c'est lui à partir de
2004 qui transforme l'ump en une machine
électorale
une machine de guerre en sa faveur et il
arrive dans un parti politique où il ya
encore des séquelles de 2012
et puis de la guerre copé fillon et
c'est là où il va ya voir l'évolution
entre l'ump et les républicains c'est à
dire qu'il change le nom du parti ça
passe plutôt sur le moment mais il ya
toujours des couches de division qui
s'empilent les unes après les autres
mais l'état de grâce de nicolas sarkozy
est de courte durée puisqu'il arrive la
primaire de la droite pour désigner le
candidat à la présidentielle de 2017
c'est par cette primaire que nicolas
sarkozy devra passer s'il veut se
représenter la présidence de l'ump
ça ça a nui à nicolas sarkozy mais
surtout ce qui m'ennuie c'est que il
avait en face de lui un certain 2
deux candidats potentiels à la
présidentielle ont imposé le système
delà de la primaire contre nicolas
sarkozy pour justement bloqué ce
mécanisme habituel à droite qui veut que
le président du parti devienne le
candidat à la présidentielle arrive la
primaire de la gauche qui se passe
plutôt bien et les élus de l'ump se
disent tiens finalement est ce qu'on n'a
pas raté le coche est ce que on devrait
pas faire pareil c'est moderne c'est
novateur
ça attire les foules donc il met en
place ce système mais quand un système
qui ne fait pas partie de l'adn de la
droite c'est pas l'adn de la vème
république telles que le général de
gaulle la l'a conçu tel écueil général
de gaulle l'a conçu c'est laurent la
rencontre entre un homme et le peuple
français est cet homme là dégager des
contingences partisanes c'est l'homme
qui décide de se présenter devant le
suffrage universel des français est
parti le suivre ou pas mais du coup ce
ne sont pas les les partis qui désigne
le candidat à l'été 2016 s'ouvre la
campagne de cette grande primaire de la
droite et du centre cette primaire est
arrivé d'abord elle est arrivée très
tard en mois de novembre 2016 et elle a
créé des écuries juppé fillon sarko
notamment qui se sont détestés qui se
sont taillé et donc réconcilier tous ces
gens après après la primaire devenait
très difficile à dire que dès le
démarrage de la campagne de françois
fillon
enfin disons qu'ils placent au centre de
la primaire les affaires avec cette
petite phrase qu'il va dire dans la
sarthe
au moment du lancement de la campagne
imagine-t-on le général de gaulle mis en
examen
et puis en plus elle à la primaire a
créé un mécanisme extrêmement pervers
qui a amené les électeurs à choisir le
candidat le plus à droite
à l'intérieur du camp de du camp de la
droite donc françois fillon celui qui
avait le programme le plus offensif
parce qu'il voulait se faire plaisir
parce qu'il pensait que de toute façon
la gauche était battu les sondages
montrent que quel que soit le candidat
la droite l'emportent grâce à françois
hollande et au fond que ce soit nicolas
sarkozy françois fillon alain juppé voir
bruno le maire vous que susco mais reese
et c'est un raz-de-marée de droite à
l'élection présidentielle c'est bon ils
l'emportent et donc ils ont choisi
françois fillon ils n'ont pas choisi un
candidat de prudence qui aurait été
alain juppé les électeurs de la droite
et du centre ont trouvé dans ma démarche
les valeurs françaises ont calé sur
d'attaché pour vous dire à quel point
personne ne l'avait vu venir c'est que
le mercredi qui précède le premier tour
je discute avec un membre éminent du
staff de françois fillon qui a bien vu
la montée progressive du vote en faveur
de françois fillon et qui dit c'est bien
on terminera 3e aux alentours de 25 30%
ça sera un bon score donc même nom ici
par l'ampleur de la vague ni le fait
qu'il va tout emporter sur son passage
et à partir du
le lendemain de la primaire même si la
gagne avec avec d'importants résultats
il y a une division qui s'installe lui
même prend beaucoup de temps pour
rassembler les juppéiste les sarkozystes
prend plus d'un mois et donc les
sondages commencent à baisser et on est
bien avant les affaires aujourd'hui on
peut vraiment dire que la primaire est
en tout cas c'est mon analyse est la
raison de l'échec de la droite à la
présidentielle
[Musique]
la victoire de françois fillon au lieu
de créer une sorte de dynamique on va
accentuer en réalité les fractures c'est
pas seulement un journal qui sort une
histoire c'est des juges tout lance une
enquête qui je pense que si on est
honnête on n'a pas cru à une victoire de
françois fillon est même le résultat 20
% des suffrages est plutôt une surprise
[Musique]